so now when we have introduced indexes
let's talk about the size of these index
tables since this is important to be
aware of when you build data store
applications using the developer console
you can see the index Isis under the
data store dashboard page here we
display the dashboard for a very simple
application and as you can see the
entities themselves they take up 6.75
kilobytes however the built-in indexes
for those entities they take up 57 point
12 kilobytes this is actually a common
scenario index very often take up more
space than the storage required just to
store the entities the building indexes
are the indexes that are generated for
each of the individual properties as we
talked about for the conference city
property there's also something called
composite indexes but we'll talk about
those shortly as you can see if you let
data store maintain an index for each
individual property it can take up a lot
of space therefore it is important to
think about which properties you need to
query on so you only generate indexes
for those let's look at how you can
control that in your code